is Monster an accurate look at Jeffrey
Dahmer's life in crimes or does it
sensationalize beyond recognition here's
the verdict on Netflix's latest True
Crime hit
the true in True Crime is sometimes a
bit misleading yes the stories are based
on real events but the people behind the
stories often use dramatic license to
make it more engaging for the viewer
listener or reader this was very likely
on the mind of Ryan Murphy the writer
director producer and creator of
countless hit TV shows as he was
developing Netflix's most recent foray
into dramatized true crime monster the
Jeffrey Dahmer story online Buzz around
the show is already electric but viewers
may be wondering how much of the story
actually happened Murphy allegedly has a
spotty track record regarding accuracy
in his projects many of which skew
toward retelling real events whether
chronicling the court cases of O.J
Simpson the impeachment of former
President Bill Clinton the feud between
Betty Davis and Joan Crawford or the
murder of Gianni Versace the filmmaker
is clearly attracted to real life events
that involved lots of drama while he
definitely sometimes embellishes reality
for artistic effect some have accused
him of stretching the truth Beyond
ignition according to Rose Law Group
actor Olivia de Havilland filed lawsuit
against FX and Murphy alleging that her
portrayal and Feud tarnished her
reputation and put words in her mouth
and the Halston family called the Ewan
mcgregor-led drama Halston which
chronicled the titular real-life fashion
designer inaccurate and fictionalized in
a statement if Murphy's detractors are
to be believed it may be challenging to
take his most recent project at face
value yet decider his fact-checked
monster and their findings draw a unique
conclusion for the True Crime genre
proclaiming that it may be one of the
most accurate True Crime dramatizations
brought to television decider asserts
that most of the series outrageous and
disturbing events actually did occur
this seems to be especially true for the
Specter of institutional malpractice
haunting this case Glenda Cleveland's
ignored police call and the failure to
save 14 year old conorak's synthesumpon
are both noted as accurate right down to
a gross joke made by one of the police
officers it'll be a minute by partner
just got to go get deloused at the
station decider argues that the show is
actually more compelling by sticking to
actual events even to the point of
showcasing an empathetic side of Dahmer
depicting him as someone who was
ultimately failed by the system still
they report that monster resists the
Trope of glorifying Dahmer presenting
him in a realistic and unattractive
light as possible while the show
explores the societal causes and
implications of Dahmer's actions the
victims whose lives were destroyed by
those very actions are always of
Paramount importance actor Evan Peters
who plays Dahmer in the series said It
felt important to be respectful to the
victims to the victims families decider
does note some small inaccuracies the
real Dahmer did not drink blood from a
bag while working at a plasma center he
consumed it from a vial similarly
Dahmer's own killer Christopher scarver
is shown to attack fellow inmate Jesse
Anderson before going to Dahmer in
reality scarver stated that he attacked
Dahmer first historical accuracy feels
especially important when dealing with
such a well-known subject as Jeffrey
Dahmer it's all too easy to forget his
victims and conjure a distracting image
of a cinematic criminal mastermind but
mythologizing Dahmer would be failing to
learn the lessons of this horrific Story
the most recent film about the killer my
friend Dahmer followed the killers last
years in high school and took a
deliberately accurate approach as well
the graphic novel the film is based on
was autobiographical its writer John
bachter began writing the story of their
friendship after news about Dahmer's
crimes became public the idiosyncrasies
he and others had seen and brushed off
were suddenly missed signals in a 2012
interview with Publishers Weekly he said
it just seems to me that at every
crucial point on his March to the edge
of the Abyss it was an adult's failure
that propelled him along the way these
themes of institutional failure and the
consequences of societal neglect are
likewise found in Murphy's monster
foreign
[Music]